I could not believe what I saw today.
Well, I'm not even shocked anymore
because this type of stuff was has been
going on for years, really. The
pro-choice movement, these activists,
so-called activists who are standing up
for women's reproductive rights and
health care and all these things that
they disguise their terminology under is
nothing more than satanic Baal Moloch
worship sacrifice ritual sacrifice to
Baal and Moloch. The Satanic Temple
openly admitted years ago they put out
some things saying that we want to have
rights to abortion and you can't make
laws against religious rights, then we
will say, "Hey, this is our religious
right to do an abortion ritual." So, the
Satanic Church has openly said that we
do abortions as satanic rituals. And
they think it's tongue-in-cheek, but
this is all deception. They don't even
realize that they are a tool of Satan.
You know, I used to be into Marilyn
Manson and he would tear up Bibles on
stage and he probably did it all for
shock value. And if you asked him if you
worshiped the devil, he'd say, "No way."
But isn't it crazy how Satan can
actually use you as a tool and make you
think, "Oh, you don't really worship the
devil, you're just ripping up Bibles on
stage. You're literally doing Satan's
work thinking that you're not doing
Satan's work." It's insane. But I'm just
going to get right into this. This
happened in Florida and it was called a
family-friendly event and you're going
to be shocked. This is insane.
That looks like Marilyn Manson.
What are these gay guys out here for?
What's It's a drag show.
Look at that.
Slapping the dead baby on the chest of
those shirtless guys.
And everybody's cheering. This is for
Christmas this past last year.
I mean, I've seen stuff like this, but
it's just I I haven't seen it in a
family-friendly setting. Um the time I
seen it before, it was some drag queen
at a bar sitting on top of the bar and
he actually cut his stomach open and
pulled out a blood sack and was filling
his cup with blood and letting blood run
all over him. And people don't see that
this is demonic and satanic that the
pro-choice movement, the choice to
murder your child in the womb is some
kind of freedom and a right. Don't take
away my rights to rip out my child from
the womb limb by limb. It is a life. And
this is insane that we've reached a
place where we are so debased that we
can't even see what it is. You know,
there are laws that protect an eagle
egg. Like if you break an eagle egg, you
can be imprisoned or fined heavily.
Uh laws that protect sea turtles and
seals and all kinds of animal life.
But when it comes to
the human life
there are actually laws in certain
states. I've heard in New York you can
actually have an abortion up to the term
of delivery. That they will actually
turn the baby around or something and
birth most of the baby and then as long
as the head doesn't come out, they can
stab the brain and kill the baby at full
term. I mean, this is insanity. This is
literally child sacrifice under the
guise of Planned Parenthood, women's
rights, women's reproductive health and
all this stuff. So, check this out. This
is what Life News said. Uh drag show
performers simulate bloody abortion at
kid-friendly event in Orlando, Florida.
This just happened at Christmas time, so
this article came out January 3rd, 2023.
Oh my goodness, this was uh a lot older
than I thought, but this is starting to
resurface, I guess. This is kind of like
a leaked video. I'm actually just now
realizing this for the first time that
this was some years old. But it says uh
the video clip of a supposed pregnant
drag queen simulating a gruesome
abortion on stage is sickening.
Apparently, the pro the pro-choice drag
queens are giving a political statement
in favor of abortion. So, anyone that
thinks that, you know, "Oh, it's just
mindless entertainment. Oh, it's just
art." That there's no real agenda, that
is just ignorance. Every form of art and
entertainment has some form of message
in there. You know, there's a a moral or
there's an agenda or there's some kind
of a message that that director that
that writer wanted to put in that movie
or play or song or whatever it is.
There's really no such thing as just
mindless
entertainment. I mean, we we try to
chalk it up as that because we enjoy it
and we don't want to feel guilty for
enjoying that. The article continues,
"Plaza Live allowed children of all ages
into the show despite a letter from
state authorities explicitly warning
that the venue's license would be
revoked if minors were permitted."
Florida's Voice and The Post Millennial
reported that children did attend the
show in Orlando, one of four tour stops
in Florida for the national tour of Drag
Queen Christmas. So,
this is just pure insanity.
Why?
I I don't understand the reasoning.
If you want to get a message across, you
should like present the facts. You know,
they're always saying this is life of
the mother and
this is women's reproductive health and
it's really not.
When you look at the statistics, how
many abortions are due to rape, incest,
and life of the mother? It's less than
1%. The majority of abortions are out of
convenience. And that's facts. That's
That's statistical facts. Now, if
there's some kind of predicament where
the mother is potentially going to lose
her life, that would be a situation
where the doctor, not an abortion
clinic, but a doctor says, "This could
end your life."
And I'm not going to say that the doctor
should give an option, but if there was
an option given, that's when it would
happen. When the life of the mother is
right there in the hospital and the
doctor says,
"You're either going to have this baby
and potentially die or we can terminate
this pregnancy." But that doesn't give
you an excuse to say, "Well, some women
die and there's also
rapes and incest, so therefore we should
have clinics all over the world for
women to just
conveniently have their child ripped out
of the womb for the choices that they
made.
We all have to reap the consequences of
what we sow. If we
have sex, then the consequence of that
is potentially birthing a child. If you
have it out of wedlock or any of these
things,
just know that that is the potential
risk. And you don't say, "Well, if I get
pregnant, I'll just kill the baby. I'll
just murder the baby." This is how
debased we are today. I want to show you
some other examples because I'm seeing a
common thread with Satanism, the LGBT
movement, and murder, child sacrifice.
I've been seeing this for years now that
whenever they have a rally, if they have
a a pride parade, you always see the
Satanists out there. You always see the
witches and you always see the
pro-choice movement. But just look at
how disgusting and disturbing this
display is of activism. They're trying
to get their point across that they
should have the right to kill a baby and
this is how they do it. This is
their logic. The Satanic Temple is an
activist organization of self-identified
Satanists.
Child sacrifice.
Uh we're talking about the abstraction
and fetishization of the fetal image as
one that speaks and diminishes women's
power and voice. Expose the violence of
abortion. That's what those posters
I disagree that abortion is violent and
I believe that your actions are violent.
That your actions are violent. So, this
lady, she's trying to keep a calm
composure even though there's this
sadistic act going on in the background
and she's trying to to gaslight these
people. These people are at abortion
clinics and at Planned Parenthood and
they're showing you what you are doing.
This is a photograph of what comes out
of you. See, nobody wants to admit that
it's not just a clump of cells. It's not
just a fish as the argument is said. It
is a human life and it has fingernails,
toenails, eyelashes, eyelids, a beating
heart.
And so, when you show that to them, when
you display the truth
because the truth will set you free and
the truth makes darkness flee, when you
show the truth in a photograph, these
people get offended and say, "What
you're doing is violent."
When that is just gaslighting because
these people are trying to show you the
truth of your actions. And so, these
people, they're just coming out and
being
complete complete psychopaths
dressed up as babies and rolling all
around on the ground
and just doing all these crazy things.
They're not making a point. They don't
have a case then they know they don't
have a case and therefore all they can
do is try to resort to ridicule and
mocking because that's what always
happens when when someone is presented
with the truth whether it's a conspiracy
theory that causes a cognitive
dissonance to go off in somebody's mind
or the earth is flat or whatever it is
the person who's hearing that receiving
that does not have a rebuttal and
therefore they call you crazy and they
just call you names
and this is just how it is. So when I
see okay who here has the better
argument? The the people who are holding
up actual photographic evidence of
what's happening when you have an
abortion or those who are rolling around
on the floor who look like they're demon
possessed speaking of demonic
possession. Like I said the Satanic
Church the homosexual pride movement
pride was Lucifer's fall
and abortion child sacrifice all go
together
hand in hand.
So check this out because this is
another
insane display.
They're saying thank God for abortion.
What kind of statement is this proving?
What are they doing? All they're doing
is proving that we're right that this is
literally the most sadistic thing you
can do is
to murder a child.
And they're literally on the ground
smashing baby dolls onto the ground and
that's their activism.
They're saying we demand abortion as we
smash babies on the ground. They're
literally showing their true colors.
Whether they want to accept it or
believe it or not that's the truth of
the matter and
these we're in the last days guys. If
you cannot see it so clearly the Bible
talks about the times that will come
when Christ returns.
But in Leviticus 18:21 it's talking
about and thou shalt not let any of thy
seed pass through the fire to Moloch
neither shalt thou profane the name of
thy God I am the Lord. So God is talking
about this
Moloch child sacrifice. This is
something that's been going on since the
beginning of time since the beginning of
Satan coming to earth and deceiving
humanity. So there was a time of child
sacrifice.
Jeremiah 19:5 says they have built also
the high places of Bale. Remember
there's a statue of Bale and Moloch with
his hands on fire. His hands are glowing
hot and people would willfully put their
born children on the hands of Moloch or
Bale and that child would burn to death
and they would do it willingly.
Wait a minute aren't we willingly having
abortions? Just because the person who's
ending the life of your child is wearing
a white lab coat
and claims to be a doctor
doesn't make it right. It doesn't
justify the wickedness that it is.
They have built also the high places of
Bale to burn their sons with fire for
burnt offerings unto Bale which I
command not nor spake it neither came it
into my mind. Now these people who are
blasting God these um
pro-choice activists who are out here
mocking Christians mocking God mocking
the Bible
they're mocking the God of love who says
do not kill your children. Thou shalt
not kill. I've come to bring you life
and life more abundantly. The God of
the God of love
they are mocking as they say give us the
rights and the freedom to murder. It's
so bizarre
and I can't understand how people can't
see through this. Like people can't see
through the deception. The deception is
so thick and we've been blinded by the
God of this world who is Satan that we
can't even see that murdering a child is
murdering a child.
It's so bizarre.
Matthew 24 this is talking about the
time we all know Matthew 24 is about the
second coming of Christ and it says but
as the days of Noah were so shall also
the coming of the son of man be. When
you really look into what were the days
of Noah like it says that only evil
continually was in the hearts and minds
of the people. All the people only evil
continually think about the world that
we're living in.
Only evil continually. What are people
doing with the majority of their time?
They are playing violent video games a
murder simulator where all day long or
for hours on end they're
murder murder murder killing people
killing people. Now let's pop in a
movie. Let's watch Deadpool or
whatever the new movies are that are out
I don't even keep up with them but how
many movies glorify witchcraft adultery
fornication
murder violence.
So this is the day of an age where we
are back in the days of Noah where our
thoughts are only evil continually.
Everything put before our eyes
is disgusting and and sinful.
We are in the days of Noah and it was
also a day of violence.
Luke 17:28 says likewise also as it was
in the days of Lot. Who was the days of
Lot? That was Sodom and Gomorrah. Lot
got pulled out Lot and his family got
pulled out of Sodom and Gomorrah. They
did eat they drank they bought they sold
they planted they builded. They were
going on with life as usual even though
it was so disgusting in that city that
God couldn't take it anymore. He said
there are none righteous in that city
except for Abraham prayed for his nephew
Lot to be pulled out of that city and
that's the power of intercessory prayer.
Your prayer can change
God's mind about a judgment just like
Moses on the mountain top when the
Israelites
were they passed through the parted
waters they get on the other side and
they begin to worship a golden calf. God
had every right to destroy them.
He they are in a relationship with him
and they committed spiritual fornication
adultery on God. He had every right to
destroy them but Moses pleaded with the
Lord and it says that God repented of
this wicked thing he thought to do and
he he preserved the life of the
Israelites.
That's the mercy and grace of God.
But we're coming in a time of Sodom and
Gomorrah.
Sodom and Gomorrah was openly known for
the LGBTQ pride lifestyle that they had
to where they even wanted to fornicate
with the angels when they came in to
pull
Lot and his family out they crowded
around the house. They were pushing in
on the house trying to have sex with
these beautiful men angels I'm I'm sure
they look glorious and beautiful because
they're perfect and they were so wicked
that they wanted to commit homosexual
acts with the angels.
Not to mention child sacrifice and all
these other things that were going on in
that day. Are we living in that time of
day?
Jude 1:7 actually gives us
a description of Sodom and Gomorrah and
it says even as Sodom and Gomorrah and
the cities about them in like manner
giving themselves over to fornication
and going after strange flesh. That
could be anything that's not your
husband or your wife is strange flesh.
It could be bestiality. It could be
children. It could be the same gender
giving themselves over to fornication
and going after strange flesh are set
forth for an example suffering the
vengeance of eternal fire.
Look guys I'm I'm trying to bring this
front bring this to the forefront
because we are living in the last days.
I don't know how much proof people need
out there but there are a lot of people
who even Christians who think look we
still got lots of time. Like it's not as
bad as the days of Noah or Sodom and
Gomorrah. Like that they were totally
wicked back then. We are just so blinded
and desensitized like the frog in the
kettle over time that we don't realize
how wicked we are. You can just go back
even 30 years when I was growing up and
the world at least the most of the
people that I knew at least claimed to
believe in God or have some kind of
morals and they thought you know
abortion was wrong and now all of it's
going out the window and we are living
in the last days. If you can't see it
please
pray for discernment pray please pray
that your blinders will be knocked off.
Get in God's word. This is the time like
no other. This is not a time to be
playing one foot in the church one foot
in the world. We need to get in God's
word. We need to pray daily pray without
ceasing. We need to be getting a
relationship closer to God than ever
before because right now
we have spiritual entities flying in our
skies. We have children
or child friendly entertainment where
it's homosexual acts of abortion and
spreading blood on each other. This is
the days of Sodom and Gomorrah.
If you can't see that you need to pray
for discernment. I love you guys. God
bless you guys. Keep seeking the truth.
We are bringing the truth here at Candid
Truth. I love you guys. We can't do this
without you. If you want to support this
ministry you can do so by going to Cash
App Venmo Zelle PayPal. We also have a
lot of cool t-shirts. If you like
t-shirts with scripture and also our
slogan is it's cool to use your brain.
Hollywood's trying to make you think
it's not cool to use your brain that a
nerd will get shoved in the locker and
it's way cooler to just be dumb and just
get drunk and hook up with every chick
you want. But, we got this cool t-shirt,
be cool, use your brain. It's got the
brain with the sunglasses on showing
that it's cool. We love you guys. We'll
see you next time on Candid Truth.